et voici chiara mastroianni qui a reçu
hier soir le prix d'interprétation
féminine la compétition un certain
regard
bravo carats bravo pour le film de
christophe honoré chambre 212
bonsoir monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs membres du jury
oui car oui vous les expliquer ce qu une
mention spéciale ou demander aux plus
grands spécialistes et bien alors donc
oui demandé au préfet le président à qui
attribuez vous la mention spéciale with
her with the special award
oui passage à l'air aussi un morlaix a
dit m d'ici là mon anglais de la
compréhension pour les anglophones mais
pour moi aussi enseigné mention spéciale
ou acquise est spécial mansion my french
in the world devenu mon français est
bien pire que transmettra smoking quand
même robin vous avez pété un câble tous
des efforts égal il y en a pour des
millions de locations ok ça y est je
n'ai donc jamais occupé cette fonction
avant